[Music]
parliamentary committees enter into
their second week of hearings of
candidates for the European Commission
in the first week MEP is quizzed 19
candidates Parliament is set to vote on
the new Commission on October the 23rd
it's time to draw up the e use next
7-year budget Parliament sitting in
plenary will debate with the European
Commission and the Council on how best
to meet Europeans expectations from 2021
to 2027 with the 31st of October brexit
deadline fast approaching the chamber
will discuss the agenda of the upcoming
European leaders summits and the UK's
new proposals to replace the Irish
backstop threats of foreign interference
and disinformation during elections have
become all too real in many countries
members will discuss in plenary the
measures needed to protect Europe's
hard-won democracies parliamentary
committees draw up the shortlist of the
three finalists for the 2019 Sakharov
Prize for freedom of thought last year's
winner the Ukrainian filmmaker or leg
sentsov was recently released from a
Russian penal colony
[Music]